what's being worked on now is 3D
bioprinting where you can use what's
called bio Inc and you can actually
print tissue definitely by the end of
the decade we'll be able to use 3D body
printers to regrow organs so so that'll
be a really amazing breakthrough I think
and it's it's it sounds like science
fiction but all the stuff is already
happening in clinical trials and animal
studies
um so it's just like a pretty
predictable road map to see where it's
going to be in like the by 2030.
[Music]
Dr Adil Khan welcome to my podcast
thanks for before we get started can you
give a brief description about what it
is you do and who you are yeah so I'm a
regenerative medicine doctor uh so what
I do is I treat people using stem cells
and plasma technology so instead of
trying to get people better through
drugs and surgery we try to repair their
tissue back to a natural state or
previous state before the injury that's
my main specialty but now because
regenerative medicine as we'll go into
has evolved so much it's not just
treating pain and injuries anymore
that's what I started traditionally but
now it's evolved into so much more and
I'm doing like clinical trials in
different areas and using stem cells for
like a broad range of applications okay
this is very cool who's your who's your
average client do you think or patient
well uh it ranges from you know like
I've had literally like you know moms
who couldn't pick up their kids and were
in so much pain and they couldn't
function
um all the way up to like the richest
man in Dubai and uh who built the whole
city uh or you know some of the rulers
of this of these kingdoms and stuff like
that so it really does range and uh the
reason is because there are you know
billions of people living in in chronic
pain actually
um and and then there's also like a lot
of people who are just looking for
anti-aging and Longevity and so there's
such a broad scope of application of
what we do
um and you know the cool thing is with
the obviously with the elite
um kind of community and like the Elite
Sports athletes and the billionaires and
stuff like that they all want to do this
to help them stay younger potentially
live longer prevent injuries and all
sorts of stuff okay I have so many
questions uh I think I think the first
question
uh like what exactly is a stem cell yeah
so I think when people think of stem
cells they usually think of like the
baby right like like this stem cell
thing that comes from a baby and that
can maybe help to repair tissue like
most people have probably heard of like
umbilical cord stem cells where it's
like you know after you give birth they
can store it or they can freeze it and
then yeah so it's like why do they
freeze it right what's that what's the
point of that
um and so obviously even 20 years they
started doing it like 20 years ago
um there was a reason and the reason was
because there was this promise that
maybe we can use these stem cells one
day to help heal tissue
um and back then we thought that you can
only use your own child stem cell uh but
the whole idea of the stem cell was
basically it can help to regenerate or
repair damaged tissue
um and so the concept of repairing
tissue is very exciting because instead
of having to cut things out or instead
of been having to take drugs to manage
symptoms you can actually repair you can
actually repair tissue so it's very
exciting and but there was a lot of
controversy back in like the mid 2000s
and like late 90s because there's there
was something called embryonic stem
cells which is where they actually make
like a fetus
um and so you make it in like a petri
like in a test tube and then you
literally take the stem cells from the
embryo and then you the embryo basically
dies right and so obviously that was
very controversial and so that's why
yeah and that's why there was so much
like heat about like a lot of people in
things except they're like oh our babies
being harmed like are you harming babies
yeah and so it's it's not like that at
all anymore because obviously that's
unethical and no one is using embryonic
stem cells uh we're primarily using
umbilical core stem cells but there are
different types of stem cells for like
you can even get them from your bone
marrow from your uh from your fat
um just so people understand there's
like two broad categories there's adult
stem cells and then there's what's
called perinatal stem cells so perinatal
is pretty obvious right it's like all
the tissue that comes after birth so
that's like placenta amniotic fluid
umbilical cord tissue and umbilical cord
blood so there's all these products that
usually that used to just get thrown
away but now we don't throw them away we
actually collect them we manufacture we
isolate the stem cells and then we can
I'm you know we literally we distribute
and sell them and we inject them and use
them for all sorts of things whoa
so that comes that's not just the
umbilical cord that's the placenta as
well yeah so that's like wow that's one
of our uh best products is it's called
purified amniotic fluid um so it's the
fluid from That's from the amnio like
Sac obviously and then you you isolate
the exosomes
um and the exosomes are like these
little messenger cells that decrease
inflammation and help with aging uh
oxidative stress and all these markers
of Aging so a lot of people use it just
for anti-aging uh Tony Robbins wrote a
book about it and just like he's been
promoting it a lot um and he's like he's
actually like you know one of our uh
people who uses the product and like
people like that just they do it every
six months just for
anti-aging and Longevity purposes
okay and what exactly are they doing
yeah so
what happens so there's there's seven or
eight Hallmarks of Aging so as we age
there's a lot of different reasons why
we age I won't go into all of them but
basically one of the main reasons why we
age is stem cell exhaustion so what that
means is when you're when you're a child
you have about 200 million stem cells
per cell and then by the time you're 80
years old you only have like eight you
only have like one million stem cells
per cell so if the whole you're going
from like you're going from like 200
down to like one basically from like
from maybe to like 80. and so it's
called stem cell exhaustion so basically
when your body stores or stem cells get
depleted you don't have the same
regenerative capacity obviously and your
ability to fight infection immune system
lots of different discus stem cells have
so many different roles your ability to
regenerate and repair tissue DNA damage
fight off infection fight off Cancer all
that stuff just decreases because one of
the reasons is you don't have as many
stem cells um so now we can do what are
called intravenous stem cells so they go
IV and they go through whole body and
they help to replenish those stem cell
stores so that's what all like the oh
and so that's what I would say all the
wealthy people are doing that basically
if you have the money you're going to do
it because it can help you live longer
and there's no downside so
hey you guys may have heard me talk
about better fed beef huge news for
those with histamine intolerance or who
can't tolerate aged Mead so it kind of
upsets your stomach when you eat it they
have unaged beef available to you now
this is extremely hard to come by so
check it out because their stock is
limited if you don't know about better
fed or you haven't heard me talk about
them they're certified Anya beef as a
game changer not only is it incredibly
tender and consistent but a recent study
by North Dakota State University no idea
how they ran the study found it to be as
tender as American wagyu but at a
fraction of the price better fed beef is
made up of 17 Midwest Farm families who
raise and care for the cattle and are
also owners in the business these
families use specialized diets designed
by PhD ruminant nutritionists
that's what they're doing at
universities ruminant nutritionists and
control all aspects of the production
process from genetic selection to
nutrition and Animal Care visit
betterfedbeef.com and use the promo code
MP at checkout for 20 off your first
order which is huge not sure how they're
making money with the 20 off coupon code
thing anyway it's huge so you can get
unaged or aged meat for 20 off your
first order
betterfedbeef.com real beef from real
families okay okay so let's get into
that then have there actually been any
long-term studies on it prolonging agent
there's biomarkers no I guess prolonging
life you don't want to prolong aging
exactly yeah exactly yeah improving
quality of life and uh delaying
um aging or slowing down aging so yeah
yes basically there's what's called
biomarkers uh so you've probably heard
of like most people have heard of like
telomere length which is like you know
one of the biomarkers of aging and then
but there's so many other like there's
inflammatory markers and there's a lot
of other ways you can measure aging and
those those markers of Aging do decrease
and there is a lot of data on that with
intravenous stem cells is there
long-term data saying hey if you take IV
stem cells you're gonna lift 20 years
longer not yet uh but in in mice there
is definitely life extension data with
the IV stem cells and
um and that what yeah oh wow I didn't
actually know know I didn't know that
that's cool
because yeah because I mean there's so
much
um you know excitement have been the
anti-aging Community uh because of the
stem cell research but it's also in
combination with other treatments that
we're doing
um which you know one of the things I I
like to uh mention is just it's
something a bit related but have you
heard about like the fecal microbial
transplants fmt
yeah so I have but but get into it for
anyone who hasn't yeah no in mice in
mice they actually showed when you take
healthy young poop literally from like a
healthy young mice and put it into Old
mice who are on the end stage of their
life it can actually extend the lifespan
of the old mice so it's pretty cool
um so there's actually life extension
that's crazy because and if you think
about it the stem cells are a similar
principle you're replacing the ecosystem
right why why does your whole body's
Health improve when you're just taking
someone's poop and putting in your colon
right it's like because like what what
is that like why it's because the
ecosystem that it provides it's a good
bacteria the signals it sends and we
know that the gut communicates with
almost every organ in your system
there's like the gut brain access the
gut disc access which means like you're
back you've got joint access like your
joints there's got lung access the point
is there's a gut communicates with your
whole body and so if you have a healthy
gut it creates a healthy ecosystem and
similarly when you replenish these stem
cells it's creating a healthy ecosystem
that's getting depleted and that's and
so and it also helps to obviously repair
the gut lining reduce inflammation and
all that too
wow okay do they have sketchy clinics
offering stem cells like places that
pump you full of things that aren't stem
cells but it's like the cheaper price
and people are there any time in the
Regina medicine is uh riddled with uh
snake oil salesmen
um and unfortunately even if you're a
medical doctor it doesn't mean you're
necessarily qualified to do the stuff
because there's no real like there's no
real faculty saying I'm a regenerative
medicine doctor you know what I mean
it's not like
um and so that's the problem there's
like very poor regulation because it's a
new field and that's one of the things
you know we're working on like I've I've
partnered with Dr Ian white who's a
Harvard scientist
um and you know and he's one of my uh
partners because uh because of his
experience and like 20 years of
experience but I get to learn from him
so much uh and and then we're you know
we're part of the American College of
regenerative medicine and
um so you know there are you can look
for like but at the end of the day it's
really hard for like the average person
to know if this is a good Stem Cell
clinic or not
um I think the only way to honestly know
is like you have to really go by like
credibility in terms of like who are the
doctors like who are they associated
with are they working with the
scientists what are their quality
control measures like are they measuring
like their stem cell profiles like there
are certain things you can look into but
I feel like the average consumer
wouldn't know how to do that like unless
obviously they and that's why we're
doing this right to educate people yeah
yeah I've I heard about because I have
people DM me whatever has worked for
their autoimmunity constantly and I had
one person DM me that who had a
five-year-old with very severe arthritis
and she's also using diet to treat it
but they went to Panama and they did
stem cell injections they didn't do an
infusion but they didn't injections
um and said that her flare-ups have
lessened
so yeah
yeah but then Panama sounds so like
sketchy yeah and Panama is yeah
unfortunately there's poor regulation
there but there is a clinic there that's
been doing it a while but the problem is
it's not that it's the doctors there too
right most of the doctors there aren't
working with scientists and like they're
just doing
um like they're kind of just made up
their own stuff I would say uh and so I
would say look into the doctor see if
they're Scalia with some sort of
institution like and so you have to work
with the site it's like I think you have
to have a scientist like the the if you
don't have a scientist like who's
um high level like you just can't keep
up with the field you know okay I think
that that makes sense uh and then
are there any downsides or do you just
get infusions of pure stem cells and
then that's it you just feel better
there's like no one has an alert like
there's nothing to be allergic to or
anything no that's a cool thing so when
stem cells like first started people
were like oh you have to use like your
kid stem cells or it has to be from your
family member or whatever uh but now we
could because we can isolate What's
called the mesenchymal stem cell like so
that's like a pure stem cell oh so
there's no what's called HLA antigen so
there's no chance of having reaction or
immune response so you can just I could
I could even take your stem cells and
put them into my body and there wouldn't
be any reaction uh but the point is it
seems like a terrible idea yeah
so if you have health issues it's
probably not a good idea but but that's
why we do a lot of strict uh testing and
um just criteria and stuff on who can
donate
um like with the umbilical cord stem
cells for example uh like the products
that we use our company
um the Dockery and White's company we we
don't
um we actually don't accept
um if they've been vaccinated right now
we still don't accept uh like whoa is
there a reason that you don't take from
vaccinated people
there is
some research suggesting that you can
trigger what's called a spike protein in
the stem cells and that Spike protein
May trigger sort of immune response in
the body and cause inflammation and
potentially make things like cause
things to get worse
um it there's some data on it but it's
not I wouldn't say it's 100 clear but
given that there might be a potential
risk we are only taking at least our
products
um are just from unvaccinated women and
donors
wow okay and so these donors aren't
there isn't like a camp in China That's
consistently keeping people pregnant and
stealing their placentas right for rich
people to infuse
it probably is but who knows but who
knows who knows what they do in China
but in uh in the U.S though uh no but uh
but yes that's that's I mean that is I
guess one of the ethical things it's
like yeah definitely it's an expensive
treatment and
um only a very few percentage of the
population have access to it right now
so that's that's wild okay so how much
uh say how often would you need to do
one of these infusions to see like how
long does this benefit last and then how
much does that cost yeah so if you're
doing like IV exosomes which are so just
so people understand so
um stem cells and exosomes are two
similar products but they are different
so it's important to understand so like
if you have like if you have like
chicken soup right the the chicken part
is like the stem cells like that's the
nucleus and it has everything and then
the soup which has the nutrients is like
the exosomes so it still has all the
nutrients in there but there's no cells
in there so because there's no cells
it's not going to reprogram your immune
system or have any asthma benefits so
the excess zones are something you
typically have to do every six months
sometimes maybe every year to get
benefits versus stem cells infusions you
can do every two to three years
typically for anti-aging and Longevity
but if you're doing it for like
autoimmune conditions or osteoarthritis
or like chronic inflammation
fibromyalgia stuff like that I mean
sometimes people like a lot of my
patients we treat it like the only one
treatment and we combine it with
peptides and uh and they're typically
they're good to go peptides peptides and
stem cells really and then they're good
to go so do they this is very
interesting I'm gonna have to try this
I've tried so many things and if I could
get more into my diet
I doubt that that can happen that way
but who knows do the stem cells go in
let's say for people with autoimmunity
and actually start you again like in an
unbroken way have you seen that happen
they just retrain it it's like oh
something went wrong the first time but
here we'll try again so it's like how
does that work yeah so it's what's
called immunomodulatory so it's
basically it is reprogramming your
immune system over time wow so that's
why it has long lasting benefits it's
the immunomodulatory component and so
but like we talked about earlier the gut
and like you know leaky gut syndrome or
intestinal permeability as it's called
um that's a component of autoimmunity as
well and the stem cells also help to
repair the gut lining so that's why it
has such a strong immune benefit
um and because of the reducing
inflammation and the immunomodulatory
benefit but and that's why I'm what my
autoimmune protocol now is using IV stem
cells with with peptides which we can
talk about in a sec and the fmt together
because then you're targeting all
so you're targeting the thymus gland
which is important part of your immune
system using the peptides and then
you're using the IV stem cells to reduce
inflammation heal the gut lining and
then you're using the fmt to obviously
help with the whole gut issues and the
immune component from the eye okay let's
do um
so with with fmt I've I've tried that I
did a lot of research into that and and
I went to a good uh I can't remember
what the clinic was called it's a good
Clinic there's one in the UK there we
used to be one in Canada that shut down
um during coved and then there was one
in the Tay Mound
was called taymount I wanted tame out
um and it like didn't work at all and
but I mean they tell you reintroduce
foods and like you know so that your
microbiome has something to eat and I'm
just eating meat and so maybe that was
part of it but I ended up um getting
really I had a c difficile infection and
it wasn't like antibiotics weren't
happening helping and um I found this
protocol online where you double
encapsulate the sample and swallow it so
that it hits the small intestine and not
the colon and that cured my C difficile
in one treatment wow and so that was
interesting and that was after I went to
tame out and it didn't work like because
they sent me home with samples too to do
myself I don't know if people are anyway
it happened I tried it I've tried
everything to like reduce sensitivities
which is what you do when you're ill
um plus I miss lettuce and things so
anyway that fixed it so when you do fmt
do you just focus on the colon or
do you ever had the small intestine uh
typically yeah we're doing it through a
colonoscopy but it is interesting to
know uh that an option orally exists
that can penetrate your small intestine
too so yeah really cool yeah yeah I'll
um I'll link that study in case
anybody's interested and I'll I'll send
it to you because it doesn't work I
could add to the protocol right like I'm
always about stacking as many Pathways
as possible to especially with
autoimmunity because it's so complex and
if you're not gonna and that's the
problem with most conventional medicine
is very reductionistic um they try to
take it down to like one thing and be
like take this pill because this will
solve all your problems but it's not
that simple as we know now no no and
probably a number of things have to go
wrong in order for autoimmunity to
happen exactly you might have to tackle
things from like like I've tackled
things from a diet perspective and that
put me in remission but like I'm stuck
it seems like I'm stuck here my
assumption was I was going to heal my
gut with the diet
and then reintroduce things with less of
a reaction but you might die so you
might need that immunomodulatory
reprogramming yeah but the IV stem cells
and the peptides could do so so maybe
maybe we'll get you come down to uh Los
Cabos or Dubai or somewhere where we can
do it for you but
definitely Wow have a stem cell party
okay peptides what uh what what do
peptides do and what are their names or
some of their names so I mean the most
famous peptide obviously is like insulin
like everyone's heard of that so that
gives people like an idea oh okay
insulin is a peptide
um but what okay what is it really right
it's it's basically like a baby protein
um so what that means is it basically
sends a signal to your body to do
something so it's very it's a very
gentle term but it's essentially a very
specific signal so insulin obviously
gives a signal to say shuttle in more
sugar take it away from the bloodstream
and put it into cells so it'll lower
your blood sugar right so that's how
insulin works it's a very specific
peptide has a signal and that's what it
does and so but now we have designer
peptides meaning you can get you can
have different peptides that do
different things so I think one of the
most famous ones because the tick tock
really is a zenpic the weight loss
peptide
um it kind of became oh yeah yeah it
like basically sold out everywhere in
the North America because all these uh
influencers were promoting it for weight
loss and then it's just like but it's a
but it's a peptide it's a glp-1 peptide
which is basically a signal in your gut
that makes you feel more full and it
helps with insulin sensitivity and stuff
like that
um so there's so peptides are becoming
more and more popular because there's a
lot of benefits and pretty much like
again like minimal risk or almost no
downside and so the peptides we use for
the immune system we're talking about
earlier is the thymus gland and so it's
called the dimension beta 1 and diamonds
and beta 4.
um and so tb1 or tb4 as a short short
name
um but basically what they do is they
can help with atrophy as the thymus
gland which is what happens as you get
older but obviously that's more in like
I would say 56 year olds
um as who get who develop immune
autoimmune conditions and then younger
people it can it can have that
immunomodulatory effect uh on the thymus
gland and helping to reprogram that
immune system and changing it from like
a pro-inflammatory state to more of an
anti-inflammatory type of state that's
so interesting it's crazy that you could
isolate stem cells from like a placenta
umbilical cord like so basically back
when you barely existed you go back to
that state and regenerate yeah kind of
well that's that's I mean that's cool
it's really cool because it's like it's
like you're literally taking healthy
young cells or tissue and you're putting
it through your body uh and it's like
who doesn't want to feel younger or like
look younger or like feel better and
stuff right it's like
um and and like we said earlier like
there's pretty much no doubt oh
okay so then
all those like wackos on the internet
that are encapsulating their placentas
or like I don't know what they're doing
eating them or putting them on their
face or something and saying that there
are massive benefits
what do you think about that could that
be stem cell related is there anything
any truth there uh I mean I wouldn't
advise eating your placenta for many
reasons but I feel like lots of people
do no I know I didn't do it I was like
that is too far but yeah the problem is
it's like there's so much other tissue
there and you're not isolating what you
need to isolate it's like the same thing
with fat stem cells and that's the
problem with these in clinics in the US
they're they're like they're like we're
offering stem cell injections they're
not really stem cell injections because
they're just taking your fat or your
bone marrow and they're processing it
and they're injecting it back in but
it's mixed in with so many other things
you have to actually isolate the stem
cells and then in a lab you have to
manufacture them or expand them and grow
them and then you can get the full
benefits from it so if you just eat the
placenta yes maybe there's some growth
factors and some stem cells in there but
you're also going to have so much other
stuff that you don't really want in your
body so there's going to be uh there's
gonna be downsides of that and that's
the problem with this whole field in
general like I feel like a lot of people
need to understand that Nuance that to
get a true stem cell or exosome you do
need a manufacturing like lab facility
to process you can't just go to if some
Clinic is telling you they can do stem
cell injections they're and they're just
taking it from your own body those
aren't true stem cells those are just
like more anti-inflammatory signals that
um the technical term is progenitor cell
uh which means it can send signals that
reduce inflammation but it's not going
to regrow your tissue okay
that's all very good to know
wow this is crazy
um I think you posted something on
Instagram the other day that said don't
do Botox do this
100 messages from women being like
please please help me yeah like what is
this magical thing yeah uh yeah I mean I
look so tired right now because like 12
a.m to buy but uh but usually I usually
I look better than this but you it with
us had a stem cell you look good the
stem cell facial um what it does is it
helps to regenerate tissue um and it
helps to reduce inflammation and
oxidative stress so the reason you get
wrinkles and you get like those signs of
aging on your face
um are three main reasons uh
inflammation oxidative stress
um and then
uh impaired ability for collagen
synthesis which means you can't regrow
that collagen as much and you don't and
then that's why you lose that elasticity
and tightness in the skin
um and so Botox obviously but it's a
neurotoxin so basically it paralyzes the
muscle so you don't move it uh but what
it does over time is it does impair
blood flow um so meaning the muscles can
become weaker actually and then so you
have to basically keep doing it or else
eventually you're actually going to look
worse than you did before you did the
botox
um and that's what and that's what
everyone gets in the trash I don't want
to hear this like well you do both I
don't know if I guess anyway but that's
but no no I do I I do I like and I have
um at least right here for a while but
that's the thing now you're either a
lifelong customer or you have to find a
different solution
um so and that's why Allergan the
company that makes Botox actually
approached us because they want us our
product our exosome product to get into
Spas because well because it can it can
fight those signs of aging um and it's a
natural alternative to and instead of
just masking it you're actually trying
to repair tissue and you're getting to
the the root cause
um so using stem cells and exosomes
together for the face can help with
actually regenerating tissue as well as
reducing signs of aging and you can
combine it like what they do at the
Mexico clinic so if you end up coming
down there we can do it for you because
they they combine it with radio
frequency which is like it's a Korean
technology that helps to tighten the
skin so they use all three they use and
that helps with collagen synthesis so
it's really cool so they do all they do
all three together the stem cells the
exosomes and the radio frequency and
it's like they're kind of like Los Cabos
energetic medicine like facial package
that they offer so
hey this episode was sponsored by
nordvpn as someone who travels a lot I
was always worried about using public
Wi-Fi and exposing my personal
information that's why I turned to
nordvpn no it's not I wrote this ad with
chat GPT is that cheating
that's not why I turned to nordvpn it's
a good reason nordvpn does keep your
personal information safe but I turned
to nordvpn to download movies without
going to jail
now I'm talking about it anyway back to
the ad not only has nordvpn kept my data
secure while I'm on the go which it has
but I've also been able to access
content that might not be available in
my current location that did happen I
used it in Serbia to get to Disney
serbians don't like Disney I don't know
about serbians but the government
doesn't like Disney weird anyway it's
been a game changer for me if you're
looking for a reliable and secure VPN
service which you should just have
turned on on your computer look no
further nordvpn is the best option out
there it's what I use with nordvpn you
can browse the internet safely and
securely no matter where you are and
right now you can grab your exclusive
nordvpn deal by going to nordvpn.com
tmpp
which is the acronym for my podcast to
get a huge discount off your nordvpn
plan plus a bonus gift it's completely
risk-free with nord's 30-day money-back
guarantee and if that wasn't enough
nordvpn also has a free anti-malware
feature to keep your device safe from
any unwanted threats again head to
nordvpn.com tmpp or use promo code tmpp
to get a huge discount off their Premium
plan and take advantage of their free
anti-malware feature and the ability to
access Netflix from different countries
and download movies
that's so cool okay I'm definitely gonna
do that I'll try that maybe I'll put it
on YouTube so people can see yeah that's
very interesting okay that's way better
I mean any any type of regeneration is
better than a toxin well obviously like
I just I mean now we're talking about
Cosmetics like I'm in Dubai right now
and like there's a there's like a
cosmetic Clinic everybody has a boob job
and like yeah but yeah but you know what
we're doing at our Clinic our plastic
surgeons now because of breast implants
all these studies coming about like you
know cancer and breast ailment yeah
plant illness syndrome and chronic pain
and all these issues so a lot of women
don't want breast implants anymore and
especially the younger generation
um and so what we offer is we actually
offer um using fat graft which is your
body's own fat with stem cells and that
can actually take it can increase your
breast size without and it's natural
um so a lot of women are doing that at
our clinic now and it's breast
augmentation
um using regenerative uh treatment so I
think that's the way that is things are
going to go such a better idea that's
such a better idea yeah boob jobs are
set like from from everything I've read
to and all like obviously such a bad
idea yeah but again like the industry
the medical these industries are all the
same right same playbooks they get into
the doctors they use their information
and they they get they make billions of
dollars and even if they get sued or
whatever they're still up you know
billions of dollars because they get
they made 20 they get sued for five and
they're still at 15.
um so that's that's just a Playbook the
pharmaceutical companies oh that's
terrible a lot of the medical device
companies have had for you for years
yeah yeah yeah that's no good okay so
how much do these things cost like how
much is one of these infusions or are
there different like levels yeah you
only get infused a little bit it's less
and yeah because exosomes are definitely
cheaper they're usually like um like 5
000 US dollars to ten thousand uh
whereas this IV stem cell treatment is
usually for like the anti-aging protocol
or autoimmune protocols usually between
20 to 30 000 us and uh so so obviously
you know it's not going to be like
something that someone has read like
everyone has readily available but for
people like like pro athletes and a lot
of um you know the wealthier people who
want to fight off Aging for them it's
something they do routinely because
there's no downside and there's so much
outside yes
um but I do think yeah but why is this
so expensive right it's it's because to
isolate the stem cells and to grow them
um it's called self stem cell
manufacturing the process is still
expensive but it's come down like it
used to cost like 50 000 just like five
years ago
um so it's come down by almost half and
so I I always say the analogy is similar
to like electric vehicle batteries like
it used to cost like 400 per kilowatt
per hour to make like a Tesla battery
and now costs a hundred dollars so it's
gone down down by like four four acts
over the last 10 years and the stem cell
manufacturing there's Innovation
happening in terms of how to manufacture
stem cells so it will become cheaper
cool and so it's gonna go instead of
being like 20 000 I can see it in the
next five years go down to like ten
thousand and then hopefully from their
five years then to five thousand right
and then then it becomes yeah accessible
to the average person okay okay very
cool and then what about one of those
anti-aging facials what'll that cost you
uh yeah that's like two to three
thousand I believe yeah so it's not bad
considering like
um it's something you don't have to do
all the time it's usually it results
usually lasts like like several years
um and something oh yeah so it's not
like one of those things you have to do
like because Botox most people have to
do like every like three to six months
right
and is it something you have to go like
Be Sedated or anything for or is it just
numbing
wow that's wild okay that's cool I'm
glad I had you on and know about that
yeah there's one benefit you got from
this
this podcast is just it's just about
people I want to learn from anyway
yeah so this is good oh okay I heard
this conspiracy what do you think about
this it's a conspiracy theory but I
believe it
um that when when covet happened
um a bunch of leaders in the Communist
Party who are old like in their 90s uh
died like you know pretty short period
of time and
um apparently they were I don't know if
this has anything to do with you but
um they were being kept alive because
they were getting organ transplants
repeatedly have you heard about like do
you think that that and I'm not
suggesting people do that because that's
immoral
in many ways but do you think that would
actually work is that just a conspiracy
theory or if you put younger organs into
people would they live longer I mean
theoretically they would right yeah but
doing organ transplants is like a big
undertaking and if you're dangerous and
then you have to take immune
suppressants right exactly and if you're
in 80s and 90s it's not a prize it what
what's much more likely is they were
probably getting fecal microbial
transplants and IV stem cells from young
babies and uh getting those to help them
live longer that's that's a much more
probable whoa explanation as to how to
live how to prevent from dying like at
that age
um but you know with what's being worked
on now is 3D bioprinting
um where you can use what's called bio
Inc and you can actually print tissue
um and so it's not we're not far off
like definitely by the end of the decade
uh we'll be able to use 3D bottle
printers to regrow organs uh so so
that'll be a really amazing breakthrough
I think and it's it's it sounds like
science fiction but all the stuff is
already happening in clinical trials and
animal studies
um so it's just like it pretty
predictable roadmap to see where it's
going to be in like the by 2030. I was
born too early I did a bunch of I I've
had my ankle replaced and that surgery
is just not good like they're pretty
good at knees they're pretty good at
hips at least in Canada
please 2007 and I was 17. so the surgeon
was like not super comfortable yeah
that's uh yeah that's too bad back then
the technology wasn't there yet but now
now what we can do if you were to have
or someone out there has like the same
issue and they want to avoid surgery is
we can actually use expanded stem cells
so the stem cells that we grow in a lab
for three to four weeks and then you can
actually use a 3D bioprinter and you can
print a custom scaffold and then you can
see the stem cells with the custom
scaffold and then you resurface the
entire joint and you regrow cartilage
that's
that is a that's I'm like irritated but
that's so good that's so good what are
you supposed to do like when are they
going to be able to regrow a foot I need
a new foot yeah exactly now we can we
we're not that we're there University of
Washington is the first shot Goliath
he's doing an FDA approved clinical
trial right now using that 3D bioprinter
technology uh but we're going to be uh
my company is going to be acquiring that
and providing in Mexico in two years
probably so okay so that's crazy this is
wild
um why are you guys in you're in Dubai
now you're in Mexico are you guys in
America or do you have to travel outside
of America for this well yeah America is
like a very interesting
um environment politically because the
FDA just to give people an idea
um 70 of their uh donations uh come from
pharmaceutical companies and so so they
inherently have uh lobbyists who want to
promote Pharmaceuticals and don't want
stem cell technology to take off and so
they're trying to regulate stem cells
wow like it's a drug and so they're
basically making it they're almost
they're cracking down a lot so anyone
doing stem cells has to be really
careful in the U.S a lot of them can't
get malpractice and get in trouble but
there's still a lot of people doing it
but there has been a lot of cases
recently where doctors even lost their
license so to me it's not worth the risk
like even though we're going to be
opening up a new facility with the
Florida Panthers in the in the summer
and so we will be operating out Florida
but we'll only be able to offer like the
first generation of like stem cells
which is what I talked about earlier
where we take the fat or the bone marrow
so they're not true stem cells they're
more just reducing inflammation which
can still help but like to be honest
like I could most of my patients like
they're okay flying over to Los Cabos or
Caymans or somewhere and we just do it
over there you know so what does the
average person do for anti-aging that
doesn't have like 20K to drop on
infusions every couple years
well or are they just going to be like
old and ugly and it's that's just life
is hard yeah it's funny my uh people
around me have been saying you're going
to create like an unethical society
which because we're working on Gene
editing too and so it's like what if
what if because you can eventually edit
jeans to choose selective and you know
eventually it's you can basically make
offspring that would be superior
genetically right
um so it's not like these things are all
gonna happen and there's gonna be a lot
of ethical things around there it's like
are you creating a superior Society
where people have access to certain
technology medical technology that other
people don't
um and it's going to widen yes and it's
going to widen the Gap that's already so
widened
um so I I don't I don't have a good
answer to that but I do say that like
the fundamentals are still the
fundamentals
um so you you know learning how to put
on muscle like sleep exercise nutrition
Stress Management and like meditation
like those are at the day are still the
most important things um and yeah like
I'm a huge fan of muscle because
muscle releases something called
myokines myokines are cytokines so
they're like protein Messengers that go
throughout your whole body
um so they go into the brain they fight
off Alzheimer's dementia they go into
the heart to prevent heart disease they
help with insulin sensitivity to prevent
diabetes
um they do what's called increased onco
suppressor genes so they prevent cancer
so there's all these cool benefits my
alkynes have
um so or so I always say like and and
this was Dr Gabrielle Lyon who coined
the term but like a muscle is like the
organ of longevity so muscle is really
the key to longevity and if you're not
strong and if you don't have that
strength you're Frailty and chance of
dying younger are much higher so that's
actually the best predictor we have
right now of longevity is muscle okay
that's good there isn't yet like a a
magical pill or something that only
means this sounds pretty much well what
we're making is we're going to make um
we're making designer exosomes so we're
going to have a muscle derived exosome
and we also have a g and we also have a
gene therapy called spolostatin it's
actually really cool so
um it's it's a company in Honduras we're
doing a clinical trial right now but um
so have you heard of myostatin yeah so
yeah myostatin is basically it's it's
kind of like this enzyme that blocks how
much muscle you can put on so if you
have a myostatin deficiency which like
some Pro bodybuilders do or if you look
up on Google myosand efficiency you'll
see these humongous cows with so much
muscle because they don't have a cup
yeah that's why I know of myostatin it's
from the cows yes exactly those muscular
cows because they have deficiency so
they can put on Unlimited muscle so
actually this new therapy that it's an
injection and it basically inhibits
myostatin
um for about a year and a half and so it
allows you to put on a lot more muscle
um so it's really exciting so I'm gonna
I'm gonna get done on myself actually
I'm excited to do it but it's gonna be
cool what how so does that give you like
well that's way better than taking
steroids right it's way safer because
it's just and it's not in your system
forever
um and this is all it's doing is sending
a signal similar to how peptides do to
turn off this uh signal to the enzyme
and it's temporary there's like no
document to side effects and
um yeah it's a really cool technology so
I'm excited to try it on myself but I
know they're doing clinical trial for
muscular dystrophy right now
um so it's really exciting that's so
cool wait does that mean if you had
atrophy must so that that's that's
atrophied muscles right yeah oh my gosh
oh I could use that in my leg
sweet that sounds good yeah that or I or
that sounds a lot faster than waiting
for someone to regrow a foot yeah so wow
that's so cool
okay okay
um what do you think about red light
therapy does any of that
like matter slash work yeah no I I
actually
um like you know I even though I'm into
all the like you know basic stuff I
still think there's other things you can
do on top of the basics to fight off
aging and signs of aging and red light
therapy is one things I use to help with
like skin aging and stuff like that like
I've never done Botox or anything like
that and I I mean I don't compare to
people in my like I'm in my uh mid-30s
like most people my age have a lot more
wrinkles I've seen and stuff like that
and I think part of the reason is
because I use red light but red light
therapy can also help you with sleep
um there's actually this cool new um
intranasal red light therapy you can use
at nighttime
um it helps with go and then nasally
because it helps to relax your brain and
helps to helps you to fall asleep and
stuff wow that's cool okay I need to
look into that too this has been very
informative
wow
interesting okay
um let's talk about PRP a little bit you
use because you said you work with
platelets right yeah so PRP is a
technology that was developed like
almost 30 years ago now
um so it was where you know we literally
just took your blood we put it in a
centrifuge we isolated the plasma and
the plasma has something called
platelets and so when you centrifuge it
it concentrates those platelets and
platelets are little Messengers
um basically that send signals to your
body to help facilitate regeneration so
what it was used for the claim to fame
for PRP was really to help injuries and
sports athletes get back through the
field faster so it's like you know they
tore a hamstring or they injured their
calf or something instead of having to
wait like four to six weeks with Physio
and stuff like that you could inject
them with PRP and they'd be back in like
two to three weeks or even less
sometimes and so that's what made it
really famous and and still to date we
use PRP a lot for the acute sports
injuries
um but I do feel like it is an older
technology now because it's as with
anything technology keeps evolving right
and so PRP was one of those things I use
a lot of in the last like five like you
know I use so much of an I used to
promote all the time and I still use it
but now that stem cells and exosome
technology is really taking off it's
almost like it's kind of like providing
old technology for at least for like
chronic medical conditions you know what
I mean like if it's a if it's like a
acute muscle tear I have a pro athlete
like I you know I had an initial guy
just a couple weeks ago he tore his
adductor he's a he's a multi-million
dollar contract so for him every week
makes a difference right so for him like
doing PRP makes sense getting back fast
as possible right
um but for like unless you're like you
know you're you have an acute injury
um I don't really see the application as
much because for chronic tendon issues
chronic osteoarthritis it just stem
cells work so much better like they have
longer lasting results uh better data
behind them and the safety profile is
the same like there's no risk with PRP
or stem cells okay but it's way cheaper
to do PRP yeah and there's still some
benefit and that's exactly and that's
the big I think the main reason I do PRP
now for like someone osteoarthritis is
just simply because they can't for stem
cells usually that's the usually why
yeah yeah okay
wow
well that covers a lot of what I wanted
to talk to you about I mean I've got way
more questions here but I mostly wanted
to know about stem cells and if there
were any downsides because when um when
dad had so akathesia and that was being
caused because he was on medications
that were causing it so there wasn't
really any regenerative thing we could
do to counteract what was actively
happening unfortunately but we were in
Florida and
and now I like and and I was looking up
everything I was like NAD we should talk
about NAD of what you think about it
anyway I was looking at NAD I was
looking at exosome therapy I was just
like I was looking at hyperbaric oxygen
I was like just
whatever could work nothing like helped
at all until the medications that were
causing it were removed like nothing
helped at all but um what do you think
about nadn
hyperbaric oxygen is there anything
there yeah no uh so our anti-aging
protocol that we have in Los Cabos we do
use hyperbaric oxygen uh with it as well
because it has again it's a slightly
different mechanism and
um oxygenation does have like especially
the the guy in Israel who likes he
started like the view of clinics and
he's like the kind of the pioneer of
hyperbaric oxygen
um and he has he's the one who published
a study showing that it can have
longevity benefits but also help with
like
um cognitive impairment so it can help
with brain regeneration and we're in my
experience it works synergistically with
the stem cells because it just it is
promoting an environment that's going to
help your body to recover and heal
um so I'm a fan of it with other
treatments like as a standalone I don't
think it's usually enough for most
things
um but as an adjunct to other things I
think it can be helpful
um and same thing with NAD like I think
NAD
um it depends on what you're trying to
use it for if you're just trying to use
it for like more energy and stuff uh I
think for that it can be great just so
people a lot of people might not know
what NAD is it's kind of like this
molecule that how it's it's in your
mitochondria which is like the
PowerHouse uh to go back to like high
school science and so basically what
happens is that and it just helps to
replenish those stores in the
mitochondria um it helps with a process
called oxidative phosphorylation which
is like the process that helps to
produce more energy
um and so it makes it makes energy more
available to your body
um and so when you replenish any when
you get older your any of these stores
deplete and so it's just helping to
replenish those uh and so you have to
typically you have to do any any IV
drips uh fairly like consistently to see
the benefits
um at least that's what I've seen
clinically and um but there are these
new cool options too like some people
are using NAD
um like patches NAD suppositories
um so they can use them on the go and
like in different situations so I think
it's becoming more accessible in that
situation did they like so
um when Dad was sick anything that like
I tested I tested on myself first to
make sure it wasn't going to do
something weird in NAD it was like that
could do something weird
um
is it always just awful like whenever
I've had NAD infusions now in three
different three different people and
they're like this big bag and you're
hooked to an IV and it's like a five to
seven hour thing unless you can like
tolerate it better and it makes me like
it's like being hooked to like a battery
I'm like not a little nauseous like a
battery and just like yeah my arms are
heavy and it like hurts and then I I had
to get up and use the bathroom and I
and I'm kind of like you know out of it
because of the the infusion and I turned
it up instead of turning it down to like
stuff yeah and then it was just like I'm
about to die anyway I got it back down
is it always like you're being hooked to
a battery or
am I like a wimp no no you're not it's
just there's um individual like response
uh like some people like when I had it I
literally felt nothing but lender I have
a lot of patience that describe it just
like yeah exactly like you do and so
um I think that sends that's that's
probably other things going on and
that's why you have to like and that's
why you have to really get to the root
cause why is your body reacting that way
right and so you're obviously things
going on in your body
um underlying maybe like um you know in
terms of like immune dysfunction and
whatnot that are probably increasing
your risk of having that type of
response to it
oh okay
okay that's interesting yes anyway I did
it a bunch of times and it wasn't like a
one-off like
um there's different concoctions you
could combine with NAD to help like
mitigate those things so
um so maybe if we like if you ever want
to do it I mean we can try a different
protocol but I don't know if it sounds
like you've had some bad experiences
with it so it's probably not worth it I
feel like I did these I think these
three stem cells would give you enough
of energy benefit
um because it does give you more energy
too
um and people feel like like I literally
had one NHL player he was 35 years old
he was thinking about retiring and uh
about six months after he had the IV
treatment done he said he felt like he
was 25 again and he's gonna keep playing
so it was pretty like that was like
that's crazy a dramatic example but it's
like amazing like Clinic like
anecdotally just to see that is amazing
that's so cool definitely going to get
my dad on this and my mom after like
cancer and everything yeah exactly
that's very yeah
yeah and yeah cool thing I just cancer I
was just going to say is that
um the micro environment that allows
cancer to happen if you think about it
it's the same underlying mechanisms
right it's chronic inflammation is like
the number one reason
um and so if you and the IV stem cell is
going to create a micro environment that
are going to reduce inflammation and
help to fight that off
wow
that's cool yeah yeah okay okay I never
actually thought I I just assumed my
like response to NAD was because nad's
horrible it's like I can't imagine yeah
suppository and just yeah you definitely
got some sort of immune dysfunction
which is why I think because you have
the sensitivity to it like
some stuff too right and so so I think
that's just a few things just a few
things yeah so there's definitely some
immune dysfunction component that's why
um I'm excited to do some treatments for
you for the peptides and stuff okay
because they'll reprogram your immune
system basically
wow I don't know you're talking a big
talk here we'll see
I've only done it once or twice so
so how long have you been in
regenerative medicine and why did you
decide
well regenerative medicine is like the
coolest thing you could be doing as a
doctor so yeah that's probably why you
decided to go into it but yeah what's
what's the back story a little bit no
honestly like I think I think most
people like I mean your dad's a clinical
psychologist too like why do we become
doctors this usually because it's pretty
simple it's like we want to help people
um but like there's so much
um almost like disbelief at the
conventional medical system for me uh I
was I was just kind of like a lot of
patients weren't getting better I was
like why are these patients like
suffering like there has to be a better
way and so I just I started studying
functional medicine I started studying
regenerative medicine and I just got so
important and like when I was in med
school like I was reading textbooks on
like intricativeness and functional
medicine like regen stuff and like well
on top of everything else and so that
way I kind of understood both
perspectives but obviously I saw a gap
because like I'm like why isn't this
stuff being applied clinically
um and then so that's how I got yeah
through the whole regen stuff because it
was really just to help more people and
like it's been like super rewarding to
help millions of people oh not millions
of people yeah but with our technology
we'll help millions of people because
now we have some proprietary Stem Cell
Tech
um but it's been really rewarding to
help a lot of people around the world so
um not just you know like the Kings and
rulers over here but all over but just
like regular people too
that's so cool
okay
um what's your thoughts on so
implementable things that people can do
that aren't these expensive infusions
you said muscle
um
muscle maybe light therapy can help a
little bit what else is there what what
can the regular person do like if I if I
find a proper nutrition like protocol
for your body like yeah well people
there's so much bad information about
nutrition and like I can I can go I can
probably talk like two hours just for
nutrition and how to but like there's
like two overarching themes I can give
people uh One is using a continuous
glucose monitor to identify how your
body responses addition Foods um because
like I could eat a banana and you could
eat a banana and we could have two
completely different responses and that
that can tell you because if my blood
sugar is going up crazy and yours is
stable then obviously I shouldn't be
eating bananas because that high glucose
is going to trigger more insulin which
is going to trigger inflammation which
is going to cause issues uh so that's
one thing and then the other thing is um
using blood work and laboratory markers
and there are so many different
inflammatory markers you can do to
figure out like how is your body
responding to different nutritional
programs like there's something thing
called Snips single nucleotide
polymorphisms so what that means there's
Snips and even like the LDL cholesterol
so if I eat a hot if I eat a high fat
diet it could cause me no issues and my
cholesterol stays good my LDL
cholesterol stays good the oxidative
stress inflammation all stays good but
someone like you or you know does you
eat a high fat diet and your cholesterol
goes through the roof and you have all
this inflammation going on your body so
those are called syntax so there's a lot
of individualization to this stuff and
um the best test out there is at least
I've seen this is called DNA code it's
developed by like one of the smartest
geneticists in the world and it uses
functional genomics to identify what
type of nutrition and program you should
make for your body
oh maybe I'll do that yeah and be like
vegan yeah just I think
he's yeah he's a smart guy he was just
he's all over the world speaking and
stuff it's really cool technology
cool okay
wow very interesting well what else do I
have on here are there any other tricks
that we haven't delved into because I
brought up
NAD and Hyperbaric and you said you guys
kind of like poke around in there too
but like what else do you do
uh I think the big the I think the big
um there's no big secret I mean if IV
stem cells I think are the big secret
and we've revealed that obviously and
how people can get access to that stuff
but like I think the big thing a lot of
people forget about really is like
um you know meditation like meaning and
purpose that type of stuff because like
if you're not like that stuff is so
important it doesn't matter how much you
invest into all this other stuff but if
you don't have like a good reason as to
like why you're like why you're living
what what's your big bigger purpose
um and you don't have that like
relaxation response when you meditate
um you're never gonna truly like be
optimizing your health and uh you know
you can throw as many tricks and stuff
as you want but that's like the base of
the pyramid in my opinion and uh there's
a lot of like tricksters out there who
are going to tell you to like buy this
program sell this and do that but you
should focus on the fundamentals first
and then worry about the you know
Superfluous stuff after
um but yeah I think that's like I I
can't over emphasize like the importance
of meditation like they're just so like
I'm sure everyone already knows but it's
just something to reiterate like having
like a routine of mindfulness that's
like you practice regularly
um that's so important yeah I've fallen
away a little bit from that I was really
into it like when all my symptoms went
away and everything and 2018 I was like
whoa okay I'm gonna do everything and I
like everything was dialed and then when
Mom and Dad got sick it was like
survival mode for two and a half years
so it's like yeah I'm not like I'm not
even going even though meditation would
benefit me now it was like if all you're
thinking about are scary things I was
like I'm not meditating my sleep
schedule got out of whack everything got
out of whack things are a lot better now
like things are great now yeah but like
I'm like I've gotten to the point in
work that I haven't been prioritizing I
mean I will it'll probably take me
another month because I've been talking
about it and then I'll just do it
there's just one video on YouTube it's
like it's a 10 minute guided one by this
like
um Indian Guru guy or someone and he's
just like it's like the most relaxing
thing I've ever found and but it's like
so it's just the way he does it and he
always talks about how the spine is the
center
um because like in different cultures
like there's like chakra there's Chi
like in different like you know China
Japan and yeah there's like they all
talk about this the spine being the
center and he just it's a really cool
guided meditation so but that's okay
yeah send that
well what do you think about
um saunas and cold plunges and breathing
techniques yeah so
lexanas definitely have like because of
especially out of Finland there's like a
lot of data from
um there in terms of like health
benefits
um at coal plunge like I'm I'm still
like a little bit skeptical about
because I don't know if it really has
real health benefits as opposed to more
just like maybe mental health benefits
like just like telling your body like
I'm gonna do this now and I don't care
how you just like and just like get your
sympathetic nervous system going and
like kind of telling your body when you
need to go you go type of thing you know
what I mean
um and being able to control your body's
response in that sense I think has put
some potential benefits
um but from like actually like reducing
inflammation in terms of long-term data
or anything like that like I don't think
there's I don't I haven't seen much on
it
um and um
yeah so I think for like cold plunges
and sauna like if I if I if you could
like if everyone could have access to
sauna it is a great thing to have in
your house or have on a daily basis
because there's again there's a lot of
upside and little downside so I I like
I'm definitely a fan of that
I like cold plunges more than I thought
I would
there's this there's this like weird
little place in Dubai that one of my
friends brought me to and it was like I
showed up on the street and it's in the
backyard and you have to go through the
sketchy gate and there were just like
tubs almost like garbage like tubs full
of ice and I was like this is this seems
like a bad idea but they had like saunas
set up and an area for Wim Hof breathing
and
um cold plunges and I think after Wim
Hof breathing after sawning and Wim Hof
breathing
maybe it's because you're on the verge
of passing out I don't know but I that
like constant narrative voice in my head
just wasn't there I remember like
looking at the sky and being and the
first thought was like oh that's like
some people don't have an internal
dialogue and I was like that is so much
better like I could hear without
thinking about hearing it was super
strange so that happened after Wim Hof
breathing and I feel like the same thing
happens with
um sitting in an ice bath which is just
like if you control your breathing and
sit in there then it's just like no
internal dialogue but it's great that's
how I felt about it anyway no and I
think that that's exactly what you said
is the key is like using the breathing
component to get the maximum benefits
out of the cold uh treatments and like
oh for sure like Patrick McEwen have you
heard he's like the he's like the guy
who wrote a book um about breathing and
like that's by far the best resource
about breathing and like how to breathe
and why breathing so important and
everything
um but like yeah like breathing is like
one of those things that should be talk
to like his preschoolers like it's so
fundamental and it's just silly that
it's not in our education system at this
point like you people don't know how to
breathe like it's just it's just it's
kind of
funny but also sad at the same time my
mom came into my grade two class as just
like a guest speaker and tried to teach
uh she did Hatha Yoga for a long time
but she tried to teach a bunch of us how
to breathe I just remember I was so
embarrassed she was like she was making
a thing of it but she was trying to
teach people like instead of breathing
up into your shoulders to like breathe
breathe out that's what she was teaching
yeah I was just like that's so
fundamental yeah well back then it was
like and I mean there was not much
concept of this whole
um no all this stuff but like now it's
like they're trying to incorporate it
but it should be literally like a
curriculum that they're taught so
um that and like you know just like a
good idea I always think about like the
lack of how ill-prepared people are to
manage their health after going through
12 years of school or whatever 16 years
of school whatever uh it depends how
much school you do I did like 20 years
of schools just but it's uh yeah but
basically the point is like there should
be it should be built into our system
about like educate people to empower
them on health right like how to how to
move properly how to breathe properly
how to eat that yeah like these are just
like it's just something personal right
like Empower people to be like take care
of their own health instead of like
relying on a system that's just broken
like I mean if you're from you're from
Canada originally so you know how bad
our system is in Ontario right now right
like it's really bad so it's and it's
like right now yeah it's getting worse
like the emergency wait times like
access to care everything is just like
broken like it's just yeah it's yeah
it's angering I was there um I didn't go
back so I moved like a year and a half
ago and I didn't go back for a long time
um especially there's a travel ban kind
of on and
um anyway I went back in October and
Scarlett got a wicked cough and so I was
trying to search for some cough medicine
and there's this company
um genexa that I really like for kids
yeah so if people need like kit and I
they might do stuff for adults too but
their ingredients they just have like
acetaminophen some like agave nectar to
make it sweet there's like no dyes and
sketchy things
so anyway good luck finding that in
Canada but she was really sick but she
wasn't going to sleep
yeah so so that was out so I was just
trying to find cough medicine because
she wasn't going to sleep all night
um and everywhere was out of cough
medicine like everywhere in Toronto
didn't have cough medicine
yeah I was like communist shelves yeah
I've seen our health care System uh
basically go from like top tier to uh
third world country in the span of a
couple years it's kind of it's very sad
uh I do have a meeting with Doug Ford
um who's our Premier I had a call with
him before I left and I have another I'm
meeting him again and when I go back
um I'm not sure if I can push the
envelope I'm not really interested in
politics but at least at least I have
his year in the Ministry of Health to at
least like give them some guidance on
how to fix their system and
um from a high level I think it's just
there's so much but I think from a high
level it's just you have to restructure
the way Physicians are incentivized like
right now it's just a it's a reactive
system you don't get paid unless people
are sick and you don't get paid unless
you see a lot of people so unless you
change that whole fundamental system
it's never really you know changed
well that's that's great good luck with
that yeah exactly exactly I'm not
hopeful
that that would be great I know but you
know in parts of China they actually
incent they actually pay you they give
you bonuses if your patients don't go to
the hospital
or if your patients don't get sick like
there's actually parts of China like
that so it's like you know oh I'm not
like that you don't it's not like you
have to reinvent a wheel like there are
people who already doing it it's just
obviously like it's the system was
designed
um by people who wanted to support
basically surgery and pharmaceuticals
not preventative care right so wow I
didn't know that about China
that's cool yeah you should be paid like
a bonus if you get your patient better
exactly that should be the bonus yeah or
if they stayed at a hospital or if they
don't get cancer or if they they don't
get heart like there's so many different
metrics you could have like outcomes to
like incentivize family doctors to keep
their patients healthy you know but
there's no there's literally zero so why
is a why is a family doctor going to
spend an extra 10 20 30 minutes with you
they'd rather just get in and get out
right like that's the only way they can
make money yeah okay
um what are the worst things you can do
for yourself to increase how fast you
age uh stress is probably the most
common that people don't realize perfect
it's like over like especially in our
modern environment and everything
um and then
sleep is another big one
um it's not just about quantity right we
know it's a quality as well and there's
so many different ways you can track
that now but uh I think that's if you're
not getting enough sleep and you're
stress and your body's just going to age
so much faster and you can see it on
people's faces and all that stuff too
um they just they just age right and
um I think glycation is another big one
which is where those like glucose or
sugar molecules attach to like the red
blood cells
um so eating refined high sugar
processed diets are gonna age you really
fast too uh and like it's very basic
stuff but like a lot of people still
don't understand because there's so much
bad information out there and there's
still so much industry that promotes
sugar in like subverts wait subverts way
like where people don't really
understand that this has sugar in it
um like most people obviously know like
about common things but a lot of people
don't realize how what a simple
carbohydrate is and how your body
processes that and all that stuff right
so
um but glycation is a huge thing because
it just ages your body internally
um and like I yeah I process foods and
the whole food industry it's I always
say it's funny like the food industry
and the so the three industries that all
have the same Playbook are the tobacco
industry the pharmaceutical industry and
the food industry they've all done the
same things over the last 60 years so
the tobacco industry did it first right
in the 60s they got doctors their
doctors used to smoke they used to say
it's good for you and then 20 years
later they're like oh wait we're wrong
about that and then Pharmaceuticals
that's really wrong and then the sugar
the sugar and food industry have done
the same thing so you always get doctors
to buy in promote it and then afterwards
they're like oh wait like and it you
know it's just it's funny if you just
study in the history a little bit you
see that they all do the same tactics
does a crazy tactic too it's like oh we
were wrong sorry a bunch of you died
yeah yeah exactly yeah but it's yeah and
that's where like as a doctor like our
job is to be able to like you should be
able to like discern like what's you
know really the truth but for some
reason like a lot I guess a lot of
doctors just stop caring but I don't
know or they're worried um because of
their colleges I mean dad's college is
going after him right now aren't you
concerned I mean you're you're in Dubai
and you said you're in Mexico but you're
not concerned about being too Cutting
Edge and
losing your license
or having your college at least
investigate you yeah I mean it's it
happened during covet because I was
making I wasn't making candy I never
made an anti-backs post but I was just
making posts about like how we should be
more nuanced about the vaccine because
there is it's like any other
prescription like it doesn't necessarily
have to be for everyone at any age like
maybe someone who's 18 and healthy
doesn't necessarily need the vaccine
like maybe the risks outweigh the
benefits
um and like I got a call from a college
about that and I was like okay this is
very interesting uh so uh it's yeah it's
crazy like and then so obviously I had
to stop talking about it
um and yeah for sure with the regen
stuff I think there could be some issues
potentially because it is very Cutting
Edge and you are taking away care I mean
you are taking away business from Big
hospitals and um there's going to be
pushback and there's already a lot of
push especially because I'm relatively
high profile now and I'm treating and
traveling around the world and treating
a lot of high profile people and there's
just gonna be more eyes on you but I
think I'm doing it with good science and
I'm working it's not like I'm working
like I'm working with a big Institute
I'm working with like a Harvard
scientist and the University of Toronto
scientists I'm working with a scientists
from Italy and Dubai like it's not like
I'm working with like some random bomb
you know like I have good institutions
backing me and I think that
institutional staff really adds a layer
of credibility that the college wouldn't
be able to come after me
um and that's why I I believe like I'm
fine I'm actually in good science and I
have good names to back me up so I'm not
overly worried and to be honest like my
move is going to be based out of Florida
anyway over the next six months and like
wheat Miami yeah Miami yeah Fort
Lauderdale so I'll be there
um because Canada's just like the
innovation's so slow and there's just
not nearly as much opportunity for
business
um so I'm just like you know I gotta and
and to buy the same thing right there's
so much Innovation going on here and
I've had like I've literally had more
business opportunities here because I
have a few companies and like in the
last two weeks than I did in like two
years in Canada so it's just like
there's just so much more going on yeah
Dubai was weird um when I I so I spent
two months I think in Dubai in 2021 and
it the opportunities are crazy like
anybody everybody there's an
entrepreneur basically that have just
congregated there so you're like you
want to start a business yeah sure it's
like what then you don't have those
conversations I mean Miami's pretty
entrepreneurial Miami's weird though
it's kind of like Caribbean slash
entrepreneurial
um but Canada it was hard to find other
people like a lot of the people who were
who felt like that just moved exactly
they're the brain dump right and like a
lot of the smart people I know are just
leaving
um and it's just it's unfortunate
because you're Canadian as well right
and so you obviously want to see your
country do well but it's uh it's sad to
see it uh go the other way and unless
the loss change is going to keep
happening like
um like whenever like our new company
regen company that we have our
proprietary stems like we're gonna
probably situate our headquarters in
like Austin or something you know what I
mean like we're there's just so much
going on in Austin there's just so much
like there's so many like intelligent
people in an Entre preneurs and stuff
and but a lot of them are from Canada
are just leaving and going to places
like Austin yeah it's too bad I'm
annoyed I really like Toronto and I
think it's just going to get like worse
yeah way worse yeah like that's what it
looks like so the government right the
bad government and bad regulators and
um they're yeah I don't know if it's
like I always wonder I'm like are they
are they evil or are they stupid like
it's hard to know well Justin Trudeau
might be evil and stupid but he's
definitely not that bright yeah like he
he's not otherwise he like would have
been doing something
bright before he got into politics right
yeah exactly so and Doug Ford is in Doug
Ford's
yeah oh well we'll see at least yeah
yeah
sucks
um okay where can people find you online
if they want to learn more
yeah I'm very active on Instagram it's
at dr.acon Khan so Dr Akon and uh I
tried my best to check my DMs I get a
ridiculous amount but uh I I do I do
believe in it because like I have been
just because I checked my DM like if
like you know because I check them
pretty regularly like I've been able to
change some people's lives and like if I
didn't check my DM like they would have
never got better
um so I do take it seriously from that
perspective as much as like it's hard to
keep up but sometimes um so don't like
and like now with the scope of stem
cells expanding like there might be hope
for people who otherwise had lost hope
um so hopefully like and like yes costs
can be an issue obviously sometimes but
um we've also we're starting a program
for people like like hardship pricing
and like you know be able to treat this
for free and stuff like that if you're
on disability like we're trying to our
best to help as many people as we can
because I think that at the end of the
day is like uh my mission at least yeah
yeah no that's really nice and I mean
when things are new they're expensive
when they're new and rare they're
expensive
so it's understandable that it's going
to cost a lot now and that it'll get
cheaper and that's just kind of how
things work yeah unfortunately
it's a great uh business opportunity and
that's why we're in the in the space now
for manufacturing yeah yeah
cool okay well I'll link your social
media handle and a couple of things we
talked about Below in the show notes but
thank you very much for coming on that
was very interesting yeah no I'll see
you in Mexico
[Music]